farm animals play crucial roles in
agriculture and food production as well
as in various other aspects of human
life here are some additional aspects to
consider breeds and varieties farm
animals come in a wide range of breeds
and varieties each with its own
characteristics suited to specific
purposes and
environments for example there are dairy
cattle breeds known for high milk
production meat cattle breeds bred for
beef production and Dual Purpose breeds
that can be raised for both milk and
meat housing and management proper
housing and management practices are
essential for the health and well-being
of farm
animals depending on the species and
production system farm animals may be
housed in Barns pens pastures or
specialized facilities designed to meet
their needs for shelter space
ventilation and
sanitation health and Veterinary Care
farm animals require regular Veterinary
Care to prevent and treat illnesses
injuries and diseases this may include
vaccinations deworming Hoof Trimming and
other preventive measures to maintain
their health and productivity
veterinarians play a crucial role in
ensuring the welfare of farm animals and
promoting biocurity on farms nutrition
and feeding proper nutrition is
essential for the growth development and
productivity of farm animals Farmers
carefully formulate diets based on the
nutritional requirements of each species
and life stage incorporating a balance
of energy protein vitamins and minerals
feed May consist of grains forages
supplements and other ingredients
tailored to meet the animals dietary
needs reproduction and breeding
reproduction is a fundamental aspect of
animal agriculture as it allows Farmers
to maintain and improve their herds or
flocks over time breeding programs aim
to select animals with desirable traits
such as growth rate meat quality milk
production or disease resistance thereby
enhancing the overall genetic potential
of the
population Animal Welfare Animal Welfare
is an important consideration in modern
farming practices with increasing
emphasis on providing farm animals with
Humane treatment appropriate living
conditions and freedom from unnecessary
suffering many farmers adhere to Animal
Welfare standards and certifications to
ensure the well-being of their animals
and meet consumer
expectations sustainable farming
practices sustainable agriculture seeks
to balance bance the economic
environmental and social aspects of
farming including the welfare of farm
animals practices such as rotational
grazing integrated Pest Management
conservation tillage and agroforestry
can help minimize environmental impact
while promoting the health and
resilience of farm
ecosystems overall farm animals are
integral to Agriculture and Food Systems
worldwide providing essential products
such as meat milk eggs wool and leather
as well as as valuable services such as
pest control soil fertility and nutrient
cycling responsible stewardship of farm
animals is essential to ensure their
welfare as well as the sustainability
and resilience of agricultural
production
[Music]
systems